WITH A SPECIFIC FOCUS ACCORDING
TO THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF TODAY
ON UNIFYING A VERY DIVIDED
JOHN ROBERTS IS HERE TO FILL US
IN.
PROUD AMERICA.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL ATTEMPT TO
OPEN AN ENGAGEMENT ACROSS THE
AISLE DEMOCRATS.
UPBEAT AND UPLIFTING IS HOW
WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS ARE
DESCRIBING PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
FIRST STATE OF THE UNION
ADDRESS.
AFTER A YEAR OF RANCOROUS
PARTISAN BICKERING AND
POLARIZING LEGISLATION,
PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL REACH
ACROSS THE AISLE.
AND A LUNCH WITH TV ANCHORS, THE
PRESIDENT SAYING "I WANT TO SEE
OUR COUNTRY UNITED.
IT WAS DIVIDED NOT JUST UNDER
PRESIDENT OBAMA OR IN
PRESIDENT BUSH.
I REMEMBER THE IMPEACHMENT OF
BILL CLINTON.
THE PRESS SECRETARY SAYS
TONIGHT'S SPEECH WILL BE A
PERSONAL APPEAL.
PRESIDENT HIMSELF COME THROUGH
IN HIS WORDS AT THE STATE OF THE
UNION.
JOBLESS RATE HELD STEADY AT
4.1%.
AFRICAN-AMERICAN ON EMPLOYMENT
DROPPED TO A HISTORIC LOW OF
620% BUT STILL NEARLY DOUBLED
THE WEIGHT ON EMPLOYMENT RATE OF
3.7.
FOURTH-QUARTER GDP DROPPED.
>> THAT'S WHY I BELIEVE IT'S
TIME TO ESTABLISH A NATIONAL
GOAL OF REACHING 4% ECONOMIC
GROWTH.
>> ON INFRASTRUCTURE, THE
PRESIDENT HOPES TO BUILD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT FOR A
$1.7 TRILLION PLAN BUT DEMOCRAT
CHUCK SCHUMER IS SKEPTICAL.
WRITING "THE PRESIDENT PROMISED
A TRILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN
INFRASTRUCTURE ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL BUT SINCE HE TOOK THE OATH
OF OFFICE, CONGRESS HASN'T HEARD
MUCH ABOUT HIS PLAN AND WHAT WE
HAVE HEARD ISN'T PROMISING."
IMMIGRATION IS A DIFFICULT ITEM.
REPUBLICANS HOPE TO HAVE A DEAL
BY FEBRUARY 9 WITH THE
GOVERNMENT.
A DEAL THAT COULD EXPAND BEYOND
THE PRESIDENTS CORE PRINCIPLES
OF A FIX FOR DACA, A BORDER
LOTTERY.
ON TRADE, PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL
CONTINUE TO PROMOTE HIS AMERICA
TOUGH ON NORTH KOREA.
ONE WHITE HOUSE OFFICIAL THING
YOU MAY BE THE MOST MEMORABLE
FIRST LADY MELANIA TRUMP WILL BE
THERE TONIGHT ALONG WITH IVANKA,
ERIC AND DONALD TRUMP JR.
SHE WILL HAVE AT LEAST 14
SPECIAL GUESTS COME AMONG THEM
AN OHIO WELDER.
THE PARENTS OF TWO GIRLS
GRAVES AN END BLIND DOUBLE
AMPUTEE MARINE WHO REENLISTED.
DEMOCRATS ARE FIELDING HALF
DOZEN RESPONSES TO THE
REPUBLICANS.
CONGRESSMAN JOE KENNEDY THE
THIRD OF MASSACHUSETTS WILL GET
THE OFFICIAL RESPONSE BUT
THERE'S A HANDFUL OF OTHERS AS
WELL, ONE INVOLVING CELEBRITIES
THAT OCCURRED LAST NIGHT AND
BERNIE SANDERS FROM VERMONT WILL
ALSO GIVE HIS RESPONSE.
IT'S GOING TO BE A LONG NIGHTS.
>> Bret: IT WILL.
NO EXPECTATION THAT HE'S GOING
TO MENTION THE INVESTIGATION OR
DOJ?
>> NO, WHY WOULD YOU WANT TO DO
THAT?
TAKING THE ATTENTION OFF WHAT
THERE.
LAST YEAR HE GAVE THE ADDRESS TO
A JOINT MEETING OF CONGRESS.
THE NEXT DAY I GOT BLOWN OFF THE